Ah, there is our song. Find a place by the pond. Bongo the bear cub is testing Gentle Log while Shelly the tortoise watches.
Garingo the parrot has appointed himself launch announcer, and Fern the fawn is studying the log.
First you sit on the log. Then Shelly pushes. Then I shout, Wheee! Safety plan complete.
BEHOLD! The Gentle Log launches at the speed of destiny, provided somebody eventually pushes it.
Um... it has not moved yet.
The safety plan is mostly shouting.
Today, Jigstar has brought a true holiday story about fear, wise choices, and courage that was not the biggest thing in the park.
God can strengthen a heart without removing every fear. Listen close; the brave part may surprise you.
Jigstar, the human boy, came down the path with a folded park map and an adventure still making noise inside him.
Can I ask you something? Why do park maps print snack stands and sky-high roller coasters the same size? That map was withholding information.
Snack stands should be much bigger on maps.
Finally, useful map-making.
Because the tallest ride is obviously the bravest ride. I would choose the biggest one, lift both paws, and possibly become mayor of the sky.
The sky has not requested a mayor.
As I was SAYING, courage deserves altitude, banners, and a speech from the newly elected mayor.
That was nearly my problem, mate. I thought brave meant choosing the tallest, fastest ride, and I wanted no part of that rule.
How many rides did you say no to? One? Two? A small parade of no?
I can carry a small parade.
Several. I had reasons for every one. Strong reasons. Organised reasons. Some of them had sub-reasons.
Were all the reasons about the rides, or was one about what somebody might think of you?
Fear, with a filing system.
A reason with pockets.
Were the reasons in ABC order? My reasons usually arrive in a heap and sit on the useful reason.
Height, speed, loops, suspicious tunnels, and whether the ride name sounded like a thunderstorm.
My ride is called Gentle Log.
Very tidy fear.
That was the reason behind the reasons. I worried Dad might think I had wasted the holiday, or that I had not tried hard enough.
That fear makes more noise than a lift chain.
I do that before a creek jump. I explain the mud, the wind, the leaf angle, and somebody else's suspicious jumping face.
The reasons can be true and still hide the smallest fear underneath.
For the record, my log ride has no loops, tunnels, or weather. It also has no movement, because Shelly has declined the pushing department.
The pushing department has standards.
Exactly. Let me tell you what happened.
As Jigstar spoke, the pond made room for bright flags, humming rails, busy paths, and a tower poking the afternoon.
We stayed at a huge resort where roller coasters passed the breakfast window. One carriage sailed by like it had an appointment with the clouds.
Breakfast with sky appointments. Fancy.
The cereal was on time.
The park smelled like warm popcorn, sun cream, and hot pavement. Somewhere above us, a lift chain began its slow metal climb.
Warm popcorn is an excellent smell and a brave lunch.
Some rides spun gently. Others seemed named by someone shouting into a thunderstorm.
Gentle Log was named in a whisper.
By the log.
I liked the river boats, the slow high wheel, and especially the bench by the snack stand. Five stars. Very steady. Zero drops.
Five stars for the bench.
Dad enjoyed the calm rides too. A peaceful moment never became a campaign.
The first coaster looked like a hurried shoelace and went upside down, so I said no.
Shoelaces should stay off the transport committee.
The second vanished into a tunnel. I said no because rides keep surprises in tunnels, and I prefer surprises to submit a form.
Forms need clipboards. I can help.
The third blew my park map into my face. I said no because it had already attacked the paperwork.
Evidence entered.
The map was a witness.
Dad listened. He did not laugh, pull Jigstar toward a queue, or call the fear silly.
After each firm no, did Dad let it stand before asking whether you wanted help with a different choice?
He let each no stand. Later he asked whether I wanted help thinking about a different ride.
So he offered help, not a decision?
Exactly. We took a snack break and sorted firm boundaries from things that only felt difficult because they were new.
Support helped you hear your own answer. Pressure would have drowned it out.
The extreme ride stayed a no. Difficult did not always mean wrong.
Then the grandest act was walking past the grandest ride.
Dad said that no was allowed. Then he asked whether there was one difficult ride I could honestly choose for myself.
THE TOWER OF ABSOLUTELY NOT. THE BENCH OF GLORIOUS PEACE. And one difficult hill of maybe-I-can.
The names need work. The choices do not.
I need objects. Pine cone: extreme no. Flat stone: easy yes. Acorn: difficult yes that might be yours.
The acorn is not the biggest one. It is the one Jigstar is still thinking about.
A modest acorn carries the entire drama. I respect its range.
So the question stopped being, Can I prove I am never scared?
They walked past the extreme ride. Jigstar kept his wise no, and Dad respected it.
Exactly. Keeping that no made the rest clearer. I was looking for one ride that matched the courage I actually had.
What made the other coaster a possible yes?
It had one high climb, one deep swoop, and no upside-down part. We watched a full trip, checked the restraints, and read the rules.
You gave the fear facts, so it had less guessing to feed on.
Dad answered each question, then left the choice where it belonged: with Jigstar.
I chose that one. My voice came out steady enough. My knees joined a drum group.
The queue moved with terrible efficiency for a line that did not know I might need another forty minutes.
The queue zigzagged beneath a shaded roof, showing the platform at one turn and hiding it at the next.
At one corner, I was riding. At the next, I was becoming a bench enthusiast. Then I remembered I already was one.
You changed your mind at every corner?
A heroic zigzag of maybe! Left turn: rider. Right turn: fancy bench.
He was deciding again at every corner.
Dad stayed beside him. He reminded Jigstar that he could still change his mind before boarding, and that the choice belonged to him.
Knowing I could leave mattered. Every step forward was still my choice, not a trap made by the steps behind me.
I took one slow breath and asked God for strength to make a wise choice, not to make me look fearless.
The coaster stayed exactly its size. Jigstar's heart still thumped. But the next choice became clear enough to hold.
I wanted my fear to leave first. It did not.
His hands felt cold, even in the warm air.
For a moment, I thought being scared meant my yes was not real. I also feared I would let Dad down if I left.
Fear said you would let Dad down. Dad had stayed kind through every no.
But you still knew which ride was your no, and which one was your yes.
No fanfare, then. The choice is brave before anybody cheers.
The gate opened. Jigstar breathed in, looked at Dad, and stepped into the carriage because he had chosen to.
The lap bar clicked. I asked it whether that was its final answer. The lap bar remained professional.
The lap bar did not answer?
Then the carriage rolled forward and caught the lift chain: clack, click, clack, climbing one careful notch at a time.
At the bottom I had six reasons to get off. At the top, the ride had misplaced the bottom.
From the top, the paths looked like ribbons. Far below, the breakfast window continued its important cereal work.
I could see the calm rides, the snack stand, and the extreme coaster I had not chosen. My no and my yes were both still mine.
The car tipped over the first hill. Wind rushed past, wheels sang on rail, and Jigstar's scared sound became a surprised laugh.
We swooped, climbed, and curved around the tower. I held the bar and laughed so hard my organised reasons flew out of their pockets.
Very untidy fear.
I prepared a twelve-part victory speech. I am placing it quietly under my wing.
There was one last curve, a bright rush beneath the flags, and then the brakes softened the carriage back toward the platform.
When the carriage slowed at the platform, Dad did not say, I told you so. He smiled and let Jigstar name what had happened.
I told him I had been brave while I was scared. I also told him I loved that ride. Both things were true.
If you had stepped away at the gate, Dad's kindness would still have come home with you. The ride could not earn it.
Enjoying one yes did not turn every no into a mistake.
Exactly. Another child might choose differently, and I might choose differently another day. My extreme-ride no still counted.
They had a cold drink and a quiet sit. The bench, Jigstar reported, performed magnificently.
I circled my ride on the map and left the extreme one outside the circle.
So the map became a record of what you chose, not a list of what you failed?
That is a kinder map.
Did you bring the map? I would like to inspect the official circle.
Right here, mate. One ride circled. Three snack stands also circled for separate research reasons.
The map is sharing more information now.
Back at the pond, Bongo had become unusually quiet. Unusually quiet for Bongo is still louder than a spoon falling into porridge, but we all noticed.
I think my mayor-of-the-sky rule was wrong.
The sky accepts your step-down.
Courage is not elected by altitude.
So the biggest ride never got to decide what brave meant?
Exactly, mate. I kept my no and chose a yes I could own.
What was the bravest thing Jigstar did?
He listened closely enough to tell fear from a boundary, and a boundary from a choice he was ready to try.
He let Dad encourage him without handing Dad the choice.
And he kept the brave no beside the brave yes. No trumpet or parade required.
Mm.
One of David's songs in the Bible says, in Psalm 31, verse 24: Be of good courage, and he shall strengthen your heart, all ye that hope in the LORD.
All ye means all of us who hope in God. It says strengthen your heart, not that your knees must stop drumming first.
Mm. We can ask God for strength for the wise choice in front of us.
Professor Hoot, the most certain owl in Shiloh Creek, settled on his lecture perch with one wing already raised.
A fact that is completely true: a roller-coaster car stores potential energy as it is pulled up the first hill.
Potential energy means stored energy, waiting to become motion. On the way down, gravity changes much of it into kinetic energy, which simply means the energy of moving.
The slow click-click climb is therefore not wasting time. It is storing the swoop. A fact, children, proven beyond dispute.
Bongo has been storing a swoop in that log.
It is currently one hundred percent potential.
Then out from the reeds came the Mudpuppy brothers, Splish, Splash, and Splosh, three frogs and one chorus of confusion, splashing in for Mudpuppy Minutes.
Today on Mudpuppy Minutes: why do socks disappear in the wash?
They become hand puppets and leave to pursue theatre.
No, louder! The washing machine eats one sock from every pair because it is building a very small scarf.
Incorrect. Socks hide inside larger clothes or slip behind the machine.
Oh no, no. That cannot be right. Too ordinary.
Maybe the sock is still inside the trouser leg.
That is the trouser's idea. The sock is innocent.
Then the scarf must be for the washing machine's winter concert.
Nah. Mudpuppies, mudpuppies, we have solved it. Missing socks are actors wearing laundry scarves.
If socks are actors, why do they perform only when I need to leave the house?
Because laundry theatre understands suspense.
Suspense is expensive.
Charge it to the scarf.
A missing sock is usually tucked inside another piece of clothing or dropped beside the machine. Socks do not leave for the theatre, though some of them are dramatic.
If something difficult stands in front of you today, little one, you do not have to prove yourself with the biggest choice. Talk with a trusted grown-up.
Keep the honest no you need, and ask God for strength to take the honest yes you are ready to choose.
And if your knees start a drum group, they can come too.
Jigstar folded his map, waved to the pond, and headed home with one careful circle still showing on the page.
Until the next brave little sound brings us together, this is Old Timber at Shiloh Creek.
See you next time, somewhere in Shiloh Creek.